[Music]
is
[Music]
and that's when i fell in love
[Music]
and now i know we'll never ever say
goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
will everybody
[Music]
that was
[Music]
come on
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
was made up
[Music]
up
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
the more you see the less you know
unless you find out as you go
[Music]
i knew much more than
[Music]
they're advertising in the skies
for people like us
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
here we go
good afternoon everyone everyone has
been working so hard
to fight back the coronavirus new
yorkers continue to go out there
doing the right thing getting tested
so much going on but this morning
we had bad news we spent some time
confirming it and double checking it
because it is
exactly on the number of 3.00
but unfortunately as of today on our
seven-day rolling average for
coronavirus positivity new york city has
hit exactly 3.0 percent
and as a result we do need to close our
schools
for the coming days no one is
happy about this decision we all in fact
are feeling very
sad about this decision because so much
good work has been put into keeping the
schools
opened and opening them up to begin with
let's start there opening the schools
when almost no other major school system
in america open
making them so safe but we set a very
clear standard
and we need to stick to that standard
and i want to emphasize to parents to
educators to staff to kids
that we intend to come back and come
back as quickly as possible
we are working right now with the state
of new york and that was a lot of what
we talked about this morning i had a
number of conversations with the
governor and our teams have been talking
throughout the morning
on exactly what it would take to come
back and bring our schools back quickly
and it will be a higher standard i want
that to be clear we have a stringent
health and
safety standard right now we're going to
have to raise that up even higher
to be able to bring our schools back but
that's exactly what we intend to do
we're going to have to focus even more
on testing and i want to emphasize
testing is going to be crucial to the
successful reopening of our schools
and everyone has got to get engaged even
more in testing
i guarantee you that part of that plan
will be an even heavier emphasis on
testing and therefore want to say to
everyone in the school communities
starting with parents and kids
we need to get those testing consent
forms in even as we're in this moment of
pause
we need to get ready to come back we
need everyone to get those testing
consent forms in
so we can get into an even deeper
testing regime
the state the governor and i spoke
several times obviously he is laid out
some of the additional measures the
state likely will be taking quite soon
in new york city additional restrictions
across the board that will affect a
number of different industries a number
of different parts of life this city
because we are dealing with a bigger
problem all over new york
city and state all over the country the
region
we have to do more to fight back this
second weight
so the state has made very clear
additional restrictions are coming and
coming soon
but what we're focused on now is making
sure
uh that we are working with all families
to get them the remote learning they
need in the interim
that we're putting more stringent
measures in place so we can get schools
back up and running soon that we can
protect new yorkers across the board
working with the state
to take the right steps to make sure
that we address the kind of activities
that might
create a particular danger and keep
people safe
it will come back every single time to
the basics to the
mask wearing to getting the tests we're
going to
keep going deeper on that but i want to
affirm before i turn to the chancellor i
want to affirm that as much as we
are unhappy today that this moment was
reached
we are resolved to keep fighting that's
what new yorkers do
and we will overcome this moment
remember thank god we're having this
conversation with the backdrop of not
one but two vaccines now
on the horizon and uh the fact that we
expect to get a lot more support
from washington going forward on a
variety of fronts so we're going to
fight this back
this is a setback but it's a setback we
will overcome
and i know our chancellor and everyone
at the doe
today is sad that this moment has come
but now
our resolute about making sure we serve
families and kids in the meantime
and then getting back up and running
with our schools as quickly as possible
let me now turn to our chancellor
richard carranza
so thank you mr mayor you're absolutely
right this is not
a happy day for us in the department of
education it's been an eventful and very
challenging year
in so many ways and to say the least but
our schools have opened and been
remarkably
safe with a 0.19 positivity rate
they've also been safe havens for our
children and we know our students
need that interaction so we feel a deep
sense
of commitment to making sure we can open
for in-person learning again
as soon as that is it is physically safe
to do so
just this morning i was visiting at ps73
in the bronx
and i want to give a shout out to
principal vivian bueno
and the smiles and the interaction of
her teachers and the students and
the love and support that those teachers
were showing for those students
is something that i cannot wait and i
know you can't wait mr mayor to see
again
very soon and we carry that same urgency
with us today as we announce this
temporary closure
and i want to emphasize that we are
looking at this as a temporary closure
we will get
students back in buildings as soon as we
can safely
this is our number one priority and our
number one focus
to get our students back in person as
soon as
as soon as possible we're committed
to making sure that our students have
what they need to be successful
and i want to remind everyone that's
listening here today
that school is still in session we are
pivoting to remote instruction
rather than the in-person instruction
that some of our students have been
receiving
so school is still in session students
will still continue
to learn and be supported by our
teachers
and i also want to remind families that
we will continue to communicate with
families about
device support and tips for remote
learning
in addition free mail meals for all
students will still be available this is
critically important
principals will work with their staff to
make sure that there are
windows of time to pick up materials at
buildings over the next several days
and as needed throughout this time
period we have focused
on these challenges before and we've
learned a great deal together
new yorkers have proven that they're
ready and willing to do this fight
against this
virus we need to ask you that again
it's important that we follow all of the
safety protocols
with the holidays coming please we
understand but it's important more than
ever that we follow the advice
of our medical professionals so that
we're able to get back to in-person
learning
as quickly as possible that's how we
will get
our schools back open to in-person
learning so again
i'm grateful for the tireless efforts of
our educators staff
and i know our students and families as
well
so please let's follow the advice let's
follow the guidance
let's take on this challenge as we've
done all along
and together we'll get through this and
we'll all get back to in-person learning
as quickly as possible thank you so much
chancellor and everyone just to put in
perspective
we made a decision to have the the most
stringent standards when terms of
the the as i like to call it the gold
standard that we put together to bring
back schools the health and safety
measures we put in place
they obviously have worked they've kept
our kids our educators our staff
safe but we also said the three percent
standard matter now to put that in
perspective
and to remember new york city is in the
middle of a battle but we
are at three percent uh new jersey our
neighbor
unfortunately now is at eight percent
chicago
third biggest city in the country 16 we
are in the midst of a challenge and we
cannot let this
challenge deepen but we also need to
take heart from the fact that we
have held off this second wave as well
as we have so far and there's still more
work to be done
that's why we will need additional
restrictions that's why we're going to
need
everyone to participate even more
everyone to get tested
everyone pay attention and act on those
core four
precautions we're asking everyone to be
a part of
it will make a difference so we have a
challenge
we're going to fight back this challenge
let me go over today's indicators
number one daily number of people
admitted to new york city hospitals for
suspected covert 19
threshold 200 patients today 114 so
we've seen some increase there but again
thank god that number still remains
lower than the other indicators
proportionally
and we still see our hospital system
doing well
but the confirmed positivity rate
continues to go up again
it is at 43.86 percent among
those patients okay number two new
reported cases on a seven-day average
threshold 550 cases today's report one
excuse me twelve 1212 twelve
again much much higher than we want it
to be number three percentage of people
testing city-wide
positive for cover nineteen threshold
five percent today's daily report is
2.75 but the number we've looked at the
most consistently is the seven day
rolling
average and that is literally exactly
3.00 percent
say a few words in spanish estamos
preparando
para el sierra de las
with that let's turn to our colleagues
in the media and please let me know the
name and outlet
of each journalist we'll now begin our q
a as a reminder we're joined today by
chancellor carranza
dr chakshi and senior advisor dr j varma
first question today goes to jen peltz
from the ap
jan jen do we have you
let's try one more time there jen peltz
can you hear us
we'll circle back to you hi thank you
very much
um i think i'm actually going to uh
withdraw my question
a lot of my colleagues thanks a lot
though all right jen next we'll turn to
emma fitzsimmons from the new york times
good afternoon mayor um so
we've been waiting a while for this
announcement um can you explain the
delay
do you want to apologize to parents
who've been waiting anxiously for an
answer were you trying to find a way to
keep schools open
uh emma look i think parents know and
they've
certainly watched me and the chancellor
that we always have been trying to find
a way to keep schools open
throughout uh this morning getting the
data
exactly on the nose of 3.00
we wanted to make sure it was 100
accurate there was time spent confirming
that there was time
spent working with the state on what it
would mean what the next steps would be
but also got to a larger discussion with
the governor's team
about what we're going to do overall in
terms of restrictions for new york city
and what it would take to bring back our
schools and we will have
an update in the next couple of days on
the plan to bring back to schools what
additional standards will be needed as i
say certainly involving more testing
we warn parents days ago that this
moment might come
but we had to be 100 sure we were
accurate this morning
and we had to have that conversation
with the state they have the ultimate
authority we have to have that
conversation with them to get everyone
on the same page
go ahead
um we were also wondering about devices
how many kids still don't have devices
and what are you going to be doing in
the next few weeks to make sure remote
learning is better
i think the chancellor said that the
system still needed 77
000 devices like ipads yeah i'll turn to
the chancellor and say the
ipads continue to be delivered and we'll
get the update uh
from the chancellor but also we continue
to work
literally student by student if there's
a problem with service
we've had a lot of concerns about our
kids in shelter we have had
technicians going out to the shelters
working family by family to make sure
their service is working
and that doesn't end emma that continues
throughout the school year whenever a
kid needs a new device or there's a
problem with device that
service that support is going to be
provided and anyone having a problem
should
call 3-1-1 still but chancellor why
don't you talk about the numbers and
also the effort today to make sure
uh kids and needed devices got them
going home so
um thank you so emma the the issue
continues to be the supply
side issue so new york city along with
every school system in america probably
in the world is ordering devices from
every manufacturer we
have in many cases been at the top of
the list so
we have approximately 40 000 devices
that
have either arrived or will arrive by
the end of this week
we have lists that have been prioritized
that schools have provided to us
given the information that families have
provided to schools
so we're getting those devices out as
soon as we get them we get them set up
we have the lte cards
installed so that number is closer to
about 60 000
devices that we know in the orbit of
students that have said they need a
device
and again we've ordered a little over
100 000 devices to be able to be
prepared to meet that need
in the interim though schools and
schools have had
some some time to prepare have prepared
paper packets of assignments
and different kinds of things that
students have to complete
so to bridge that time gap between a
student that needs a device
and and actually gets a device as well
so again
it's going to be incredibly important
that families stay very very close to
their schools
there they they can also go on to our
department of education website schools
dot nyc
dot uh gov and there is a link there
where they can also
connect with any support that they need
for
either logging on or their email account
or any of the connectivity issues as
well
this will be just a continuous process
of getting devices into the hands of
students we know that schools have also
assigned some
of their own in-school devices for
students to take home during this time
as well
so all of that is happening as we speak
it's happened
as well and we continue to as we receive
those devices get them back into the
hands of students
go ahead the next is rich lamb from wcbs
880. good afternoon mr mayor and
everybody on the call
um mr mayor it appears that you and the
governor
are using two different sets of numbers
in regard is how is that possible at
this point and why
can you get on the same page or does
that make sense
rich the state and city throughout
have had a different system it's not
news it's been reported before i'll have
commissioner choxey speak to it and it's
not surprising that different levels of
government might have different
approaches they lead us in the same
direction consistently the state and
city
have been very highly aligned throughout
but each entity and this true with
federal government or any other part of
government is going to have its own
approach what we know is that
we put forward the standard related to
the schools
based on the city's way of counting
testing and that is based on the day
the test was taken not when the test
result arrives the day
the test was taken we simply believe
that's the best
approach that's the standard we use with
our indicators
that's the standard we set related to
our schools
and the state understands that and we
all have communicated and they
understand that's the approach that
we're taking
go ahead commissioner thank you mr mayor
um
yes our commitment is always to provide
the most
accurate uh and valid data that we
possibly can because we know
uh what momentous decisions uh are made
based on the accuracy of that data
one of the major differences as the
mayor has already pointed out
in the way that we count test positivity
the percentage posit
positivity is by ensuring that we
count based on the date that a test is
taken
rather than the date that we learn about
the result
from the test this becomes particularly
important
when we are seeing an increase in cases
as we are right now
because it allows us to see the trends
over time
and that's one of the key things that we
have to discern
to make good decisions based on the
accuracy of the data
and rich just to say i think it's
important
the state of new york and the city of
new york both squarely
fall in the healthcare conservative
philosophy
there's just not a doubt about it when
you look at the whole history of
coronavirus and the whole country
new york city and new york state have
been amongst the most
cautious data-driven science-driven
entities jurisdictions in the whole
country
and both our standards are interpreted
with a very
focused approach to protecting people's
health and safety
ours are particularly conservative as
the commissioner just
pointed out but again state and city
have
really followed the same path as you
know a lot of other places have not and
unfortunately to their peril
go ahead rich mr mayor
also could you give us a sense you're
talking about more stringent standards
are you
are you and you did say more testing in
the schools but
uh does that mean you would roll uh back
those you know rolling number would
actually have to be lower
than three percent for you to bring the
schools back is that essentially what
you're saying there
no it is not that what what i'm saying
to be clear i appreciate the question
rich
we're look we understand that there's a
bigger problem in this country and it's
affecting us
we also understand our schools have been
extraordinarily safe
to protect school communities we're
going to have to put a different
additional measures in place we're
talking right now
with the state on what those should be
one thing i can tell you up front will
be an even heavier emphasis on testing
and one thing that i'm going to be
adamant about is that
when we reopen uh everyone who comes
into that
school building all the kids have to
have
a testing consent on file so we can test
them
whenever we need to because testing is
going to become more of the norm
and it's been crucial to protecting
everyone
but exactly the point which that we were
having
conversations with the state in detail
today about what that reopening standard
will be
i expect that announcement to be at some
point
this week of what the reopening standard
will be and then we're going to apply it
as quickly as we can put the pieces
together
so that we can get to that reopening but
those details are being worked on the
one thing i can say for sure
is a lot of testing uh will be necessary
the next is christina vega from chalk
beat
hi mayor thanks for taking my question
um i would love to hear
a little bit more about how long this
might last
uh we keep hearing that this is
temporary but we're also hearing that
the requirements to reopen are still
being developed
so can you give us a sense of what how
long this might last
absolutely i think speaking to my fellow
parents about
how to prepare you know i said last
friday
get ready for this and get ready to have
alternative arrangements
i know that's not easy it's very tough
for parents and for some parents
single parents in particular really
really tough i don't say it with
anything but sorrow but
we gave people a warning to think about
it for the remainder
of this month so certainly through
thanksgiving
uh school will be closed we're going to
see with the state
how quickly we can finalize those
standards and then what we'll have to do
to
meet those standards uh that week after
thanksgiving is the earliest but i'm not
yet able to save it will be then or a
point thereafter but we have
real work to do which i think we can do
quickly
to finish those standards and then put
together the action plan to make them
come to pass again heavy emphasis on
testing and we're going to be deploying
a lot of our testing capacity towards
the schools under this new
model even much more than we've done
previously
but certainly parents should assume
obviously we're closed for the rest of
this week
and the days leading up to thanksgiving
in the meantime we'll fill in that blank
christina and make very clear
what the plan is to come back
go ahead thanks and my next question is
about um
you know the last time we had a citywide
school shutdown there were the emergency
rec centers in place i know you've said
that learning bridges will
remain open but can you talk about how
enrollment is going to work in those and
how much space you have and whether
people will be able to attend full-time
because
those were set up only to serve children
on a part-time basis when they weren't
in schools
correct this is a different model you're
absolutely right christina but i think
it will help us achieve some of the same
things so
um i'll get the specifics in front of me
i know there was
um some city testimony earlier to give
some of the details on what attendance
has been
so far but i can tell you the bottom
line is essential workers
will have a preference for the learning
bridges seats for their kids
and there's other folks are prioritized
families in shelter for example
and families that have particular
challenges so
we're going to make those seats
available
we have seen surprisingly little
uptake on the learning bridges seats so
far
obviously this moment will mean more
people will want them but we don't know
how many
but we certainly feel confidence based
on the experience we had with the
regional enrichment centers that we'll
have the seats for essential workers who
need them
and then if we need to keep adding we
can quickly
ramp up toward the number we originally
projected but so far christina it's
actually been very
low enrollment in the schema thing so
there's certainly a space available
right now for the families who are going
to need it right away
the next is katie from the wall street
journal
hey good morning um mayor de blasio my
question i guess following up
from christina's question is why wasn't
there
a reopening plan kind of summer
was first created or came up or agreed
upon by the city
and other entities it seems uh i know
that
we had a look and so just decided but
shouldn't every possibility have been
explored so that's
been it yeah katie perfectly fair
question
i think look we set a very stringent
standard with the three percent
extremely conservative standard um
we've now seen a lot of changing
conditions some things that have been
much uh better than i think a lot of
people projected in terms of the safety
within the schools a very low positivity
level but then we've seen this
unfortunate resurgence around the
country uh which has added
additional challenges so as we were
going about the work of our schools
initially honestly this day seemed far
off thankfully
as it has come closer there's been a lot
of moving parts a lot of changes
what we do know is under any scenario to
turn to a new system takes a little bit
of transition time
and we know it has to be a more
stringent system
so these next days uh none of us is
happy about but these next days will be
that retooling time
uh to figure out how to most quickly get
school back and with whatever standards
we need
uh and to work with the state to make
that come to life but i think uh
there's some cases where when you're
dealing with changing situations you
actually need
the best information the most recent
information and now we certainly know
what we're up against and what it's
going to take to bring back our schools
go ahead katie and my second question
about that is to uh as a
the threshold and go to the update
when it comes in looking at this updated
number after
can i just stop you for a second your
voice is skipping a lot so i'm not
getting your whole sentence could you
try again
sure so my question is about the city's
data it gets filled
with it results we actually city
two percent for three percent flat weeks
how can this three percent threshold
people when when you're updating the
numbers we actually hit it last week so
can you i knew that coming in but does
it again give the most accurate measure
to do this thing that affects so many
people when the numbers fluctuate
and yeah i could hear i could hear most
of it i think i
i got enough and i'll start and turn to
dr choxy look
let us all acknowledge that none of
these measures is perfect by any stretch
you're exactly right that even when we
provide
a morning update there still as
information comes in after
but we tried to create the standard that
whatever the numbers were that morning
that's what we were going to be governed
by
in the end these are still choices
they're not perfect choices but they're
directional choices
we wanted to take a very cautious
approach
to protect the health and safety of kids
and
educators and staff that was from the
very beginning
chancellor and i said more times than we
could count that we would be
prioritizing health and safety in the
reopening of schools and that's what we
did and that's what we did by setting
that three percent threshold
so the standard we said is the day that
we hit that
based on the indicators we had that
morning was when we would act we did not
expect it to come down to exactly
3.00 but that's what happened but i
think the important point to say
is that the the question is direction
the question is what is the basic
approach you're trying to take
and clearly we have seen an uptick
steadily unfortunately for the last few
weeks
clearly we saw that this kind of level
was being reached that's why we were
warning people
late last week it's not perfect but it
does
tell us where we are and what we need to
know commissioner
well the mayor covered the the high
points we're always striving to find the
right balance between
providing the most recent data as well
as the most
accurate data if we were purely going on
having uh you know the the utmost
accuracy um then that would mean that we
would be reflecting a reality from
several days ago
so the balance that we strike is making
sure that we're providing a picture
of the most recent and most accurate
data together
but i just want to underline another
thing that the mayor said
which is let's not miss the forest for
the trees here
um and really focus on what are the
concerning signals
uh in uh what we're seeing with test
positivity
um and with cases as well which really
demands
all of us to redouble our efforts so
that we can
focus on what's most important over the
coming weeks doing the things that we
need to do
to try to get schools back open as
quickly as possible
as well as protecting our fellow new
yorkers
thank you the next is narmine from pix
hi good morning it's not even morning
anymore it's afternoon sorry about that
uh you know the governor said
that if new york city gets to three
percent then we go
to orange now i now understand how the
city
and the state determine their numbers
differently but whose are we going by at
this point
to determine when we will go to orange
that point seems to be a bit confusing
mayor and also
should we get on the same page when it
comes to determining some big changes
for the city
norman i totally understand why it feels
confusing and we
we have tried intensely to put
information forward to help people
understand again it is always true i've
never seen a situation where
you know federal government state
government local government were always
perfectly seamlessly on the same page
it is not the reality because they're
all built differently they all have
different missions
the question is not uh sort of a
legalistic are we always saying exactly
the same thing exact time the question
is are we moving in the same direction
that is unquestionably been the case
again i give the governor and the state
credit
they've been cautious and conservative
and data-driven science-driven
throughout this process
that's what we've strived to do as well
but it is also understandable that our
job is to protect the people of new york
city
we're going to collect the data in the
way we think makes the most sense
we're going to take the measures that we
think are important
uh and we've done that consistently so
we said here's what we want to do we
told the state in the initial
submissions about our schools
here's our safety plan here's our a plan
for cleaning
for testing for ventilation for social
distancing mask wearing
and we said we have this three percent
standard
and it's based on our data and the state
has across the board consistently
deferred to local jurisdictions on a lot
of the decision making about school
systems
which is consistent with how school
systems are handled in general they're
not run by any state they're run by
localities but on the question of the
zones and the phases
before that that we talked about those
have always been the state's domain to
make the ultimate decisions on
we proposed uh an idea to the state when
we saw brooklyn and queens happening
that focused on zip codes they came back
with a variation on that
that variation proved to be very
effective they came up with the red and
the orange and the yellow zones
it worked brooklyn and queens were
surging in the wrong direction those
neighborhoods
i put forward my proposal the state
turned it into something that they
thought was going to be particularly
effective
they applied it we worked with them and
we pushed down the positivity in
brooklyn and queens in those
neighborhoods
very clearly and really there was a sea
change
the same history applies to the phases
phases one through
four the state determined
when we moved from phase to phase we
worked with them to make that happen
it worked every phase was done on time
two weeks
between each one and we progressed
through them so
there's been a lot of coordination there
continues to be
but now the numbers that the state will
use
to determine if we go into an orange
zone or a red zone that's
their numbers and we respect that and
and they're being very clear about
get ready for that because that's a
that's something that is
likely to happen at least orange zone
likely to happen
based on their numbers and the timeline
they've laid down
go ahead we've been talking a lot about
children and testing in schools and
while the random testing has been
occurring there i do have a question for
you in terms of children who have been
remote what's your recommendation to
families while you're urging all new
yorkers to continue to get tested
what do we do with our children who are
in remote they're obviously not locked
up in their homes they've been out and
about as well
get tested i'll turn to dr choxie who is
a dad
and happens to be married to a assistant
principal so you can do it better than
me but i'll start
everyone get tested whether you're doing
remote learning or
in person everyone get tested go ahead i
don't have much to add to that sir
i agree with that recommendation if
children
are getting remote learning
they should also get tested and the
reason is the one that you mentioned
i mean you know people are interacting
out in the community and we also know
that there is
transmission that occurs uh within
households you know among family members
so we're encouraging everyone to get
tested this has been our consistent
message over
uh months now but is particularly urgent
uh
as we see uh spread continue to increase
go ahead the next is michael garland
from the daily news
good afternoon mr mayor hey michael how
are you
i'm good um so a couple questions on the
um
school closure um we'd heard that
um for a long time uh
some of your top health advisors um
have been questioning the threshold um
you know given the fact that the three
percent
city-wide threshold is is we're seeing
something different than what we're
seeing
as far as transmission in schools and i
was wondering if
you know dr choxy and uh dr varma could
address that if you could address that
what has been going on behind the scenes
as far as
the the discussion on the use of that
three percent threshold
and and whether it's um you know i mean
clearly we're closing schools now so
it's applicable but
you know i mean could you tell us about
that you know we're hearing there's been
some debate within your administration
about the use of that
yeah michael there's definitely been
some debate but healthy debate
um you know everyone uh
so many i shouldn't say wrong but the so
many of the folks
in this discussion are
parents themselves or aunts or uncles or
grandparents or whatever it may be
and and cherish
public education uh also
our healthcare team is a very cautious
conservative team
and they're built that way and so
the whole conversation has been filled
with that
natural tension that we are
we've followed a cautious conservative
strategy it has served us
well in terms of the focus on data and
science
leading us to decisions that brought the
city back
from being the epicenter that allowed us
to open our schools that allowed us to
keep the schools safe
but you sort of you know you live by a
standard
and sometimes you know it feels better
and sometimes it feels worse but it's
still a clear standard and so that three
percent was a really
conservative standard uh and
of course we've all felt some pain that
we the last thing we wanted to see is
the school's close
but but there's been resolve about the
fact
that the the game plan so often has
worked
of sticking to those tough standards and
that's why i'm resolved about the fact
that to bring schools back we can do it
we've done it before we'll do it again
but we have to come up with even tougher
standards
dr choxie thank you mr mayor um
well look uh as the mayor and the
chancellor
have said this is a tough day from the
education
perspective but i would just say as a
doctor it's also a tough day from the
health perspective
because we know how important education
is to younger new yorkers not just for
their development
but frankly for their health as well and
so
you know as the mayor has pointed out i
think we have to be forward-looking
in this moment one of the things that i
love about being a doctor is not just
being rooted in
science but also um you know having the
humility to say
we have to learn from experiences we
have to learn from evidence
as it emerges uh so that we can make the
best decisions on behalf of the people
that we're trying to serve
and i think our focus going forward will
be
on ensuring that we bring to bear
the rigorous safeguards but also
standards that help us to maximize
the health of the children of new york
dr varma
great no no thank you i and i i think
what what the commissioner and the mayor
have said
is really spot on and i'll go ahead out
front and even my own biases
you know my my three children attended
new york city public schools for
uh seven years um so i have a deep and
and
and strong uh connection to them um and
i've also spent my life working around
the world
trying to prevent infectious diseases so
this is a
very difficult decision and we made it
with as the mayor has said intense
debate about
how do we ensure that we have the most
rigorous health and safety precautions
possible
and how do we make sure that we're also
delivering the education that we can to
the kids
and establishing the trust that's needed
from parents from from
the staff uh from the whole community
about this and so
um we we did intensely debate and have
continued to debate this and
i think the value of that debate is that
uh we're going to look at ways at which
we can
um uh uh strengthen and revise our
protocol so that we can get the schools
um back to in-person learning as quickly
as we can amen go ahead michael
the other thing i wanted to ask you
about is just kind of
the a little bit of the
the tick tock on what happened from you
know
10 a.m uh this morning to three today
we'd heard that um you know earlier this
morning
that the school chancellor had um
reached out to uh you know the the
unions
um or the the uh administrators
and said you know schools are schools
are gonna shut down
and then soon after that basically
pulled it back and said well no hold on
we're in a holding pattern so
you know i mean given that the way we've
seen like with this this briefing today
you know what was going on as far as the
discussion
it seems like um you know there was
discussion right up to kind of you know
what became public
as to what you know your administration
was going to
do on this can you kind of fill us in on
on that shirt
michael michael i think two key uh
elements
one as i said uh the data came in right
on the razor's edge
that caused some understandable pause we
wanted to be 100
certain you know coming in at 3.00 we
want to make sure a
hundred percent of that was accurate i
wanted that checked again
before coming to a final conclusion and
also i want to have a thorough
conversation
with the state including several
conversations i had with the governor
because it was about what happens
immediately as a result
what does it mean for getting schools
back and how are we going to get skills
back quickly
it was important to talk that through
before either he or i
uh addressed the public and we had
several good conversations and we agreed
on
the kinds of things we're going to have
to do and now we have to codify that and
make that a formal announcement but
that's what we really
wanted to think through because it's the
natural next question
are schools going to come back we
believe we can get them back
and get them back soon what's it going
to take it's going to take some
additional
measures and we believe we can achieve
them but we've got to codify them and
make them real
and we also talked about the
restrictions uh
that are coming and again no one is
happy about the notion of
any other restrictions to our economy or
to our lives
but the numbers are speaking loudly and
additional restrictions are coming
we talked about what the state is
thinking about how the city
could implement it and so all these
pieces interconnected
but clearly a lot of folks have asked
you know
look talked about schools talked about
other parts of our economy and different
things happening different activities
all of those things are going to be
affected obviously by this growing
challenge
and we're working through with the state
exactly you know how much and when
and that's what those conversations were
about
we have time for two more for today the
next is jenna deangelis from cbs
afternoon mr mayor can you hear me yeah
how are you doing
good how are you good good
we're faced with the second wave and
more people getting tested but people
are running into
incredibly long lines especially at
urging cares
so what's your recommendation to those
who are facing this issue
especially if they have symptoms and may
be worried about
being in line or taking public
transportation to get there
i've got some simple advice and i'll
have dr choxie
amplify it turn to our health and
hospital sites
uh you know just by calling 311
you can find a site near you
overwhelmingly
our health and hospitals we have the
hospitals we have the clinics we have
the pop-up sites
they generally have not had longer lines
uh they've had very fast turnaround with
results
so it's right there for people as a
great option doctor
that's right mr mayor um no i'll just
add to it by saying that
uh we're working every day through the
test and trace core through health and
hospitals as well as the health
department to
expand our capacity for testing for new
yorkers
but we already do have many options that
are available
you can find them by going to nyc.gov
covid test
or calling 212 covid19
to find the most convenient testing site
close to you
go ahead so for those who don't live
near a health and hospital
site and they think they've been exposed
to past symptoms
are they supposed to stay home and order
an at-home test
stay local and wait in the lines or take
the train to another location because
that's an issue that some people have
expressed to us
very good questions go ahead doctor yes
thank you these are very important
questions and i just want to pull out
you know particularly you're talking
about
people who are experiencing symptoms
those are absolutely the most
important people that we want to get
tested
to get tested quickly so that
we can take steps to make sure that they
isolate
that helps us break the chains of
transmission
understand who their close contacts were
so that they can also
quarantine so to your specific question
itself
they should find the closest site to
them from any of those resources that
i've mentioned
if they do have to take public
transportation to get there
they should of course you know make sure
that they are wearing a face covering
uh to and from that but the most
important thing is to get tested
very soon once you're experiencing
symptoms
thank you go ahead last question for
today goes to jake often hearts from
gothamist hey good afternoon
hey what are you doing okay
uh just trying to get a clear picture of
what happened today really
uh did you did you make clear to the
governor that you planned to close
schools
because he seemed pretty surprised by
this turning the presser when your
tweet went out no i spoke to him before
um i i didn't see his presser but we had
you know a
number of conversations in the course of
the day we've been talking over the last
several days
about this possibility obviously
and this specific
exact moment that the press release was
going out he might not have known about
because we had to get information out to
schools before they left but he
understood it was coming for sure
go ahead jake okay
um and i mean on the on the
testing discrepancies between the city
and state you're saying that
you know both the city and the state are
really closely aligned
um i think for a lot of parents and
people in new york doesn't really seem
that way
it's been a pretty head-spinning day uh
we were from parents
this morning who heard there was a rumor
that schools were closing
and there were delays in your briefing
repeatedly
several hours in which we heard nothing
from city hall
um then cuomo held his own briefing he
said the
city positivity rate was 2.5
acted surprised as i mentioned um
i'm not really hearing anything in your
press for today that suggests this was
mishandled or perhaps not fair to
parents
jake so i mean go ahead go ahead
what were you going to disagree with the
premise i mean i could i
i suppose is it is it fair to say that
nearly nine months into the pandemic
there are still
issues with the way that the city and
state are not on the same page
and do you think that's hurting new
yorkers um
no is the simple answer and again
i i don't you you do know me well jake
and there are times when i'm going to
question the premise and i think
when i question the premises to try and
help truly answer
the point um
this is a very big decision we had to
make sure it was right
but again you know what when a decision
happens you guys rightfully are going to
say well now
okay what's next and and what's the plan
to bring it back
and all those and we had to get clear
and make sure city and state really had
talked all that through
it doesn't always happen on you know the
exact timeline
that we normally keep to because it's
complex stuff
very good very productive conversations
we have warned people i mean new yorkers
are smart they've been watching these
indicators
for days and days unfortunately go up i
gave a very explicit warning on friday
that people had to get ready with
alternative options for their kids
the vast majority of everyday people are
smart and they understand
when they're given a warning like that
that they have to get ready but again
today
the information coming in right on the
razor's edge really important to confirm
that
really important to talk through with
the state the exact next steps
i found the conversations very
productive very consistent and i would
say if you just take the eight months
i will put the whole thing up
again there sure were there a few times
or disagreements absolutely
if there were never any disagreements
that would be very surprising to me
but if you go directionally have the
city and state both been
data and science driven yes compared to
a lot of places in the country
extremely data and science driven have
we
consistently got to the same directions
yes have we worked together in a sense a
lot of times the state would come up
with a concept we had to implement we
found a way
there's going to be tensions but the
job's been getting done
and we we came back from the worst of
this disease
overcame that became one of the safest
places in the country opened up the
nation's largest school system made it
extraordinarily safe
but we also are living by those cautious
conservative standards and we hit this
day
and we're following through but now we
turn to the exact
focused strategy for how to bring them
back and i'll conclude on that to
everyone
look there's going to be obviously
so many parents right now are saddened
are frustrated
and the kids can't go to school tomorrow
so many kids want to be in school so
many educators want to be there to greet
them
but now we put ourselves to the work
of overcoming this challenge and we
apply ourselves with everything we've
got
and that's what new york city has done
time and time again
i know our schools are going to come
back why do i know it because they've
come back from a lot worse than this
we were told a thousand times we
couldn't reopen
in uh the summer richard and i wherever
we went we're told we were crazy to talk
about reopening schools
we did it we'll do it again and it takes
tougher tougher standards we will live
by those tougher standards but this is
how we will deal with the immediate term
i want to turn people's attention to
what comes thereafter because
there are fully seven months ahead after
this month there are seven
more months ahead in the school year and
during that time we will get the vaccine
and we will distribute the vaccine and
we will make the city safer and safer
and more and more kids will be able to
come back
uh we are going to be able to do a lot
more in the school year so
today is a tough day but this is a
temporary situation
our schools will be back and our school
year will get better and better as we go
along
and this disease will be beaten in the
course of this school year i have
absolute faith
and we will make this a year that works
for the parents and
kids of this city that's what we're
committed to
and to everyone keep fighting because if
you're hearing this news today and
you're
feeling it all let down with it the
thing to do is to fight even harder
make sure everyone's getting tested make
sure everyone's wearing the mask
everyone's practicing the social
distancing
be smart about the holidays this is
what's going to allow us to overcome
this moment
bring our kids back to school bring our
city back thank you everyone
you